hey what is up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tech channel of the week episode the
original mkbhd series and uh yes first
of all guys i am back and the wallpaper
link is in the description uh anyway
this tech channel of the week is
actually number 10 so kind of like a
semi sort of a milestone tech channel of
the week number 10 uh but yeah just
gonna hop right into this here guys this
channel is called boyco brand and uh
this is actually one of my uh favorite
youtube channels uh just because of the
nature of the channel now being the tech
channel of the week obviously uh does
produce a number of tech videos uh but
i'm just gonna give you a quick tour of
this channel before you go ahead and
check it out yourself uh at the link in
the description uh so i'm just going to
scroll down here to go ahead and check
out the channel specs uh and this
channel is very new uh actually well it
was joined he joined youtube in november
of 2007 which is just like me i joined a
long time ago but he just very recently
started making tech videos a few weeks
ago
so as you can see here he joined
november 20th 2007 uh his name is brad
he has 725 channel views he has watched
a little over 6400 videos and he has 30
subscribers i would don't be deceived by
that number uh the thing is this youtube
channel is starting exactly the same way
as i did this youtube channel he started
and he's been making a lot of quality
tech videos
uh in a short span of time and really
getting his content out there uh at
first and that is basically how i got
started i made about a hundred videos in
a month and a half two months and really
got my act together and started making
you know the same quality videos just
spread them out a little more and make
it easier for subscribers
so you can see uh he's got a pretty cool
looking background going on here
for the youtube 2.0 layout going with a
blue and black theme here
now if you scroll down you can see you
can read a little bit more about what
he's like you know what he likes to do
uh but basically the highlight of this
channel is the content the videos you
can see his last couple of videos were
actually uh he did it he started the
tech channel of the week series like a
lot of other youtubers have after me
uh he has some hardware videos and some
software videos and he has this video
series called appige which are actually
application reviews uh for i believe he
has an ipod touch
now if we go ahead and go uh to the most
viewed section you'll actually see that
one of them was uploaded two days ago
and it was a gameplay video and this one
has 300 views i actually favorited that
one because the music in the background
which i plan to download later uh but
most of these up here uh are hardware
videos as you can see he has uh one
hardware video here he has the flip mino
hd and actually the unboxing was
actually uh the video that got me hooked
on this channel and uh there are quite a
bit more videos here now i don't know
the exact number of uploads but as you
can see in the last two weeks or so
there's been a lot of cool videos uh put
out now let's go to the the top rated
section and there you go the unboxing of
the flip minnow on which i actually plan
on getting something of that nature and
lg voyager review and i have an lg
voyager as well so that's that's a big
reason why i like this channel
another thing you guys might want to
check out is the recent activity box
which is where he can sometimes you know
post announcement videos
so uh if you disable a number of things
in the recent activity uh like in the
privacy section you can pretty much
limit it uh to your own bulletins and
announcements so uh he just reached 30
subscribers
and i guess that's you know it's a big
thing when you hit 10 by 10 by 10 it'll
start going up exponentially you'll get
a lot of subscribers uh now
over on the left hand side you also see
he does have a twitter so i'll go ahead
and throw that link in the description
if you guys want to check that out uh so
far but i mean this channel is really
great this channel like i said man if
you're watching this now this is exactly
how i started on youtube i started uh
with a channel that i didn't really use
that much until i decided to make tech
videos so i don't have a tech name but i
just started making a ton of screencasts
i mean he has variety already but i just
made a ton of screencasts so guys if you
want to go ahead and check out this
channel boycobrand the link will be in
the description so go ahead and uh take
a look at that and i hope you enjoy so
thanks for watching this tech channel of
the week number 10 i will continue to
make these pretty much every week if not
you know i mean that's how often i've
been making them so far and that is
basically it guys so thank you for
watching and uh thanks for chilling with
mkbhd
peace